COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SEVENTH IS HEREBY CALL.
LE PICHET BISON AUDIO ANDVIDEO
FORTY OF THESE PROCEEDINGS
TEAMMATES HAS ALSO BEEN
TELEVISED.
ABOUT SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CALLING HERE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO YEAH CERVANTES HERE
GALLAGHER GRAYSON HERE
KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE.
MAYES NAZARIAN PRESIDENT SALAS
WALDRON HERE WE HAVE A FORM.
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVEN'T
CONSIDERED JENDA.
JOB MOST ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
MOVE.
UBER MISS WALDRON SECONDED BY
MACHINE IS AREAS.
AMENDED SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HIGH COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO KIND CARILLO
AYE CERVANTES AYE CERVANTES AYE
GALLAGHER GRAYSON BY RACE AND I
KAMLAGER-DOVE I THINK
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MAYES.
MAYES AYE AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SALAS WALDRON AYE
WALDRON AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSED MOTIONS
PASSED AND THE SCHOOLS
COMMITTEES MEASUREMENT.
THE CENTER